game two this abbreviated two game
series
the dodgers against the houston astros
dodgers victorious last night in game
one
but there has been some fallout joe
kelly receives an eight-game suspension
for major league baseball that is on
appeal
he is here he is dressed and he is
available tonight dave roberts on the
other hand
was uh suspended for one game so it's
going to be bob garan at the helm
tonight for the dodgers
christian javier making his big league
starting debut for the houston astros
three levels in the minor leagues last
season he was the astros minor league
pitcher of the year
compiled a 1.74 era so it'll be
muncie hitless in his last 12 advents
he's ahead owen two and tries to get a
swing and he does a three-pitch
strikeout of max muncie
to start this one quite a beginning for
christian javier
so now he will face mookie betts
called third strike mookie betts goes
down
looking and javier has struck out muncie
and bets to start the game now it's cody
bellinger
and there's a swing and a miss how about
that first inning of a first major
league start
muncie bets and bellinger all go down
dustin may will have his hands full
against the astros this afternoon
98 with elite movement to it
two and two on kyle tucker here comes
may
and he slides one under the swing for
strike three now two out alex bregman
coming up
off the end of the bat cutter at 94 then
moved off for the barrel and helped
dustin may get a one two three first
now corey seeger is the hitter the 1-0
there's a liner to right and deep and on
his way
and gone a home run corey seeger
with his first home run of the year
dodgers take a one to nothing lead
cory singer has reached base now in all
six games that
have been played jack peterson the
batter did not play yesterday 2-2
swinging and a miss got him on a high
fastball that's five strikeouts for
christian javier
this one ends the inning bottom half of
the second inning astros trail one
nothing
may will face michael brantley bradley
hits one hard to right field and that'll
be in there for the
a base hit and one hops into the crowd
just above those cutouts
about two men in scoring position quite
the spot for miles straw to get his
first plate appearance of 2020.
there's a ball towards the right side
with straw speed he's going to beat it
out
rbi infield hit for miles straw 1-1 game
there's the speed
hamstring looks fine watch the speed of
miles straw
you can kind of see him take a peek at
dustin may the pitcher
sized him up and all of a sudden went
into sixth gear
dropped the hammer and just beat him to
first base
1-1 ball game with the dodgers and
astros matt beatty here's the one-two
and that is strike three called the
breaking ball froze baity
and that's six strikeouts max muncie the
batter he struck out his last time up
swinging a miss christian javier seven
strikeouts through three innings
getting muncie a second time out is
uh dustin may in is jake mcgee
two on two out and it's the eight hitter
miles straw there they go here it comes
and he struck him out with a fastball
christian javier
javier has retired 12 of 13 and seeger
hits a line drive one hop spear by jose
altuve
and corey seeger retired on the nice
play by the astro second baseman
pretty snazzy pick out there in the
shift in
shallow right field for jose altuve
bottom seven
tied at one caleb ferguson who struck
out the side yesterday on
14 pitches putting together back to back
here
one out of the bottom of the seventh and
the one
two swung on man missed strike three a
slider
two out and kyle tucker coming up
ferguson looking for a one two three
frame
and he's got it the cutter to the inside
corner to get tucker still nodded at one
both runs scored in the second inning
we're now in the bottom of the ninth
kenley janssen
dodgers closer in the game he got this
now george springer is going to come up
and pinch hit for maldonado
all four the winning run moves into
scoring position
kyle tucker who is one for four tonight
with a single
here's the o2
strike three janssen gets out of it the
inning is over
the first and third two out and here is
mookie betts who is oh for four mookie
bets
swings away lifts a fly ball to left and
deep that ball is
off the wall and betts is delivered here
in the 11th
hernandez into score on a mookie bets
double that puts him in front 2-1
the astros have the tying run 90 feet
away and the winning run at first base
with nobody out for carlos correa
there's a ball on the right side we're
tied up at two apiece carlos correa
the rbi single mayfield scores
and the astros have tied it at two edwin
rios
leads it off needs 2-2 rios turns on it
high drive to right field it is gone
[Applause]
edwin rios with a two-run home run here
on the 13th to put him in front
4-2 and he knew it you saw it with that
gorgeous follow-through he knew that he
had produced
probably the biggest swing of his young
big league career
the third goes mayfield and to the plate
comes a pinch hitter
santana comes out here's his 3-2
he struck him out what a wild ride
this one was it ends in a 4-2 win for
the dodgers in a two-game
sweep over the houston astros